okay now I wants to think about this a
bit more visually because I've got I've
got a number now but I want to think
about what this means
underneath here could you draw for me
please
a nice little Cartesian plane but we
only need the first quadrant just need
the first quadrant because we're dealing
with positive things here I'm not
interested in negative speed at least
not yet anyway
so let's just get a little Cartesian
plane here this will do this will do now
you can see I don't have the entire
plate here but I've got enough of it
that I I need now we would normally call
these X or Y but I'm interested in these
quantities here right speed is made up
all these two quantities what are they
again yeah dependent interdependent the
dependent one we would normally call
this vertical axis which I guess makes
most sense the distance so I'm gonna
call this the distance axis I did that
depends that depends on the way I mean
I've changed I've just changed this
around right so I want to think about it
as distance per time right so in this
case in the original case it's like yeah
we know it's fixed and the time is not
changes but I've now switched it around
the other way okay so I've got a
distance axis going up and I've got a
time axis going horizontally now just
for this particular race right we know
that the distance he hit was a hundred
meters and the time it took to get there
was nine point six nine seconds okay
yeah another color here we know they all
start at the beginning at the blocks
there and then after nine point six nine
seconds have elapsed so time is gone
from left to right and he ends up at
this 100 meter spot okay now just look
with me for a second after you've got
that down at what I'm about to draw
because I want to come back to the video
that you watched and pose your question
about this right we know he starts time
zero at the blocks and he he ends after
nine point six nine seconds up here 100
meters right so
it's tempted to draw something like this
just a straight line
from the beginning to the end but can
anyone tell me why this is not an
accurate representation of what actually
happened there's at least two reasons
then what do you understand
okay number one so he's accelerating
right he doesn't start out at the blocks
and just it's instantly going at the
speed that he's going the whole time
right in fact if you pay it we saw it
like five times right at the beginning
who's a bolts like he's just in the
middle of the pack he's not at the front
at all so this takes some time to
actually pick up right that's at the
beginning and then of course there's a
second thing that he does and the
commutator is made a big deal anyone
else notice ya arrested yeah at the end
he actually what he does is he's running
and I think with about 20 minutes to go
he looks he looks around to see where
the competition is and he realizes he
can't save him so he's just like oh I've
won in video he puts his arms down beats
his chest and he just so slows down
right and that's why the commentators
are all like what time would he have run
if he actually went all the way what we
actually with the benefit of time we now
know what time he would have run if he
didn't you know pull any punches so
we've got problems here with this graph
number one at the start this is not
what's happening right it's not
instantly going at that speed and at the
end it's the same problem right so I'm
going to draw a new Cartesian plane but
you don't need to you've got yours there
can you draw for me it doesn't have to
be perfect Jonathan Lee a better graph
than this one I'm gonna draw one
underneath draw for me what you feel is
more accurate it's still gonna have the
same beginning and the same content but
can we get a more accurate shape here so
I'm gonna do my best
okay so I'll give you perfect but the
first thing I notice is as a cue pointed
out he starts off really slow but not
just he starts off slow everyone starts
a speed of zero no one's going anywhere
right so they're kind of not going
anywhere right like the distance has not
changed at all in that first instant
after the gun goes off right but then of
course he picks up right he gets faster
fast this is when that lead sort of
takes over okay and then at some point I
mean not super accurate he saw slows
down he's like oh okay well I'm just
gonna use your imagination okay it
doesn't keep on don't we get the same
rate nor does it get faster he looks
around and he just slows down at the end
um you'll notice by the way I haven't
drawn this flat across the way I had
this flat down here why do you think I
didn't make it flat at the end do you
remember what he did in the race yeah
he's still running right and that's why
the colored head is like the 100 meters
is still it's just a straight line but
he's gone all the way around the curve
because he doesn't stop at an instant
that would probably that's gotta be like
you say about hitting a brick wall which
would that be bad for his leg not like
that so this is better right now when we
talk about speed remember we said it's a
distance over a time have a look at this
up here right where is the distance on
here on this on your graph right I'm
gonna do this twice actually
can you mark out this whole distance
here right now this distance here on our
graph is vertical so you could call this
the rise yeah that's how far he's gone
vertically on the graph and then we
divided by time which is over here on
the horizontal axis so we wouldn't call
this rise we would call it run thank you
very much so when we think of speed as
distance over time what you're really
calculating here is thirty seven point
one five number right what it really
represents is the rise over run what is
this called this is called the gradient
thank you very much
so I'm actually going to put this maybe
you want to put it at the front as well
when we were at speed what we were
really calculating was gradient but we
were calculating it over the entire
journey the entire nine point six nine
you can clearly see in the middle of all
of our graphs is the point where he's
going fastest right he's not doing it
for the whole time but if you wanted to
draw on there mmm yep I've got mine
black you see how I've got like one big
triangle here one big right angled
triangle like so if richer you like a
smaller one in here in this fastest
point I want you to look at your graph
and I want you to pick the portion of it
it's gotta be somewhere in the middle
that is the steepest right the part
that's the steepest that would represent
where he's going fastest does that make
sense it's the most change in vertical
or the most rise over the smallest
change in time which is run okay biggest
rise
smaller sponsor just obviously pick it
on your graph I think mines around here
so you can dress off in a nice little
right angle trying there and just like
on mine can you represent you've got the
rise here and then you've got the run
okay
now let's see where's my thing good here
we go service is this could we get the
lighting in place
stay okay now here's what I'm trying to
show you here right
this was our bogus model for her is head
bolts run we quickly because we you've
only watched it like once but you
immediately dismiss it you're like
that's that's not what's happening right
a better model looks more like this
right it's not perfect I had to I had to
cheat a little bit because you can see
it actually does stop that's the is a
bolt hits a brick wall version but you
get the idea right it's better than a
straight line right so I'm gonna get rid
of that straight like you now what we're
thinking about here is trying to get
this the steepest part in here
okay but there's a problem in that what
we draw our little triangle right
you're still measuring a section and
that section might not like he's getting
faster during that section so if you
think about this right I'm gonna put a
point in here depending on where it is
that you measure here can you I say that
maybe around means here right depending
on where we measure what you're
calculating if you think about an actual
distance which is a vertical thing and
an actual time which is a horizontal
thing you're always going to get
something like this I'm just gonna hit
play on that right so you can see this
is like the hypotenuse of your right
angle triangle so that makes sense this
is the hypotenuse moving around
obviously down here as you can see it's
getting flatter that represents is a
boat running slower right is that okay
and as you get to this middle section
here this is when he starts getting
faster and faster faster I'm just gonna
hit pause about there okay now just have
a look at this spot here this spot is
interesting to me because it looks at
on this particular graph that the
straight line here it's always a
straight line let me just put it back
you can see no matter where I put it on
the graph that black thing is straight
this is a spot I want here at this spot
the black line is small enough even
though it's straight that it looks
almost indistinguishable from the
original does that make sense right it's
on this graph if I went somewhere else
you're like oh um somewhere like hold on
what am I done here we go so we like
there these are clearly two different
things right but then again if I looked
at this spot if I zoomed in a little
closer I know that looks more
exaggerated but watch this right I can
say let's make that black line smaller
if I make it small enough do you see
that even though it looks very obviously
different before if I pick something
small enough now again it's sort of
indistinguishable isn't it if you could
make a small enough triangle you're
following with me